millions of years before industry
agriculture and civilization the world
stage was set for one creatures
unprecedented rise the story of
humanity's evolution began about seven
million years ago when the human lineage
broke away from that of chimpanzees over
time an ensemble cast of over 20 early
human species or hominids came to the
fore most became extinct while others
might have been ancestors to today's
humans each species exhibited varying
degrees of human-like physical and
behavioral traits such as large brains
small teeth bipedality and tool-use
these hominids fell into three major
groups early hominins australopithecines
and Homo genus humanity's earliest
relatives lived between seven and 4.4
million years ago in Africa having most
recently shared a common ancestor with
chimpanzees they had many a black traits
such as a small cranial capacity however
fossils show that some ancient hominins
were also beginning to show human-like
characteristics such as small canines
that were likely used more
and not for hunting or fighting the next
phase of hominin evolution involved
primates called Australopithecus they
lived between 4.4 and 1.4 million years
ago across the African continent like
their ancient brethren
australopithecines had some ape-like
traits
however changes in the skull spine and
legs indicate a notable shift toward a
very human-like trait consistent bipedal
locomotion the third and current phase
of human evolution involves members of
the genus Homo
the earliest homo species likely date to
more than two million years ago making
them a contemporary of semi
australopithecines but unlike earlier
hominins who exhibited a mosaic of
eighth and human-like traits homo
species were becoming distinctly more
human their cranial capacity was growing
larger than any other hominids they
developed sophisticated stone tool
technology and they became the first to
control fire these physical and
behavioral adaptations along with
advancements in technology allowed some
homo species to be the first to migrate
out of Africa and explore the rest of
the world
while a cast of over 20 hominin species
have walked this earth only one remains
Homo sapiens shaped by millions of years
of evolution embarked on a journey of
exploration and Industry its ancestors
could have only dreamed
[Music]
you